you
organic and in the United States has a
very precise meaning it's what the
Department of Agriculture defines it as
and it defines it very precisely for
plants as no genetic engineering no
irradiation no fertilization with sewage
sludge no chemical fertilizers or any of
those kinds of things it's very precise
definition of what can and cannot go
into a food that is called organic with
that with animals the definition is also
quite precise the animals have to be
raised on organic feed they have to have
access to the outdoors they can't be
treated with antibiotics or hormones and
so forth is the rules are very long and
to the examples and the places that
produce those organic animals or plants
are inspected to make sure that they're
following the rules so that's that
system and to the extent that it works
it works pretty well most people think
it works pretty well and there's not an
enormous amount of cheating going on
because of the inspection system and
because the organic producers know what
the other ones are doing and so they
turn each other in if there's a problem
there's not a lot of cheating going on
but with that said a lot of people feel
that the organic rules are not strong
enough that they really don't deal in
particular with the ability of animals
to be outdoors just because they have
access to the outdoors doesn't mean they
are actually afterwards that's a big
loophole and also there's no requirement
for sustainability so you can have
industrial organic agriculture that is
just as devastating to land sea and air
and climate as industrial anything else
and that's I think a problem i think the
department of agriculture is looking at
ways to strengthen the organic rules and
ways to make sure that they're kept
honest